ravi singh is the head of the australian
sikh association he represents a faith
that's considered a minority religion in
australia but is the fastest growing he
says despite its rising popularity it's
still widely misunderstood in the
country and is often vilified by some
members of the public
sikhs look different
to a normal person veering turban than
sporting beards
so
in a way it's a
it's a
very difficult situation for for growing
kids especially in the in the schools
legislation proposed by australia's
parliament would have offered protection
to people who felt exposed because of
their own religious beliefs and such
discrimination in their workplace school
or university would have been banned but
critics argued the bill would enable
prejudice against other groups including
gay teachers and students and should
cover all forms of discrimination
it was amended to include laws
preventing religious schools
discriminating against students on
grounds of their gender and sexuality
that caused division in federal
parliament and the bill was shelved
politics should be left out and it
should be all about people who they
serve
so at the end of the day everybody
should be treated equal
some community leaders say it's not just
a matter of discrimination but also of
safety
since the massacre of 51 people by a
gunman in an attack on two mosques in
christchurch three years ago
members of some religious groups say
they feel targeted and this bill offered
greater protection
women are concerned about wearing the
veil and stepping outside because of
the attention that attracts the
vilification etc and certainly we've had
direct reports where women for instance
think twice before they step out
many in australia consider the country
promotes a multicultural environment but
there are no national laws specifically
protecting people against religious
discrimination
if they're raising concern they feel
that their rights are being undermined
their religious rights and it's
something we should take seriously the
religious discrimination bill may be
shelved for now though some faiths are
hoping that federal parliament will
revive it but given the contentious
nature of the debate that's unlikely to
happen anytime soon and a federal
election is expected by may this year
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia